this morning we're looking at how you
can turn a gap in your resume into an
advantage in your career it's part of
our series with LinkedIn called work in
progress
re-entering the job market after taking
months offer even years off to care for
a parent or raise a family can be very
stressful but a recent study shows
companies are now ok with interviewing
job seekers who've been out of the
workforce for as long as two years that
marks a shift in attitudes toward work
gaps LinkedIn senior editor at large
jesse hempel is here Jesse good morning
welcome why is this why our employers
attitudes changing well there are two
reasons and the first is the obvious
unemployment is historically low yeah
recruiters need job candidates but the
second is more interesting and it's that
culture is changing essentially I mean
when my parents were looking for jobs
you were expected to leave work at work
at home at home but in 2019 you blend
the two and in fact employers are much
more supportive of their employees and
in fact their job candidates
prioritizing life outside of work so how
do you turn this gap in your resume into
an advantage that is the question and
it's a question that people have been
talking about on LinkedIn and one woman
had a great piece of advice she said you
need a plan you need to go into that job
interview with a story and when I say
story I don't mean a confessional that's
not what a job interview is just be able
to explain it concisely don't hide it
yeah but it certainly used to be a
negative because what have you just said
I don't really want to talk about it
it's a personal matter for me are you
expected to share with your employer to
be what happened that's an awkward it's
an awkward question for people who maybe
aren't as comfortable sharing personal
information yes and yet it is expected
you have to be invited to share you
don't need to over share this is the
problem particularly for older people
often for women like you don't need to
be too honest just need to explain why
this fits into the pattern of your
career yeah is this change happening in
part because Millennials are now aging
into positions of power they're the ones
making these hiring decisions and they
may have taken years off to go travel
when they were in their 20s and what
that speaks to is why people take time
off in the first place right and most of
the people on LinkedIn we're still
taking it off for a very traditional
reason
they had children to take care of at
home an aging parent it's men and women
by the way who take time off for
caregiving
but Tony what you speak to is this next
wave that is people coming into the
workforce and saying you know I'm gonna
take a year off and travel or I'm gonna
take a year off and take this coding
boot camp so I'm better prepared for the
future and those are proactive reasons
to step out of the workforce so somebody
a good employer might look at that and
say oh that's that's a curious person
you were saying yeah that person has
that person really is thinking about the
future that is a proactive person for my
organize that's a modern interpretation
around an old-fashioned good my family
that means flaking off yeah that doujin
person do you think companies are
becoming more flexible and open to two
to two allowing people who've had time
off who have taken time off to re-enter
the workforce without judgment
absolutely within reason though I'm not
gonna try to tell you that this is an
easy thing and in fact the people
talking about it on LinkedIn didn't all
have great stories to recount about how
it all worked out what are they saying
yeah they're saying essentially that
they go back in with a plan some people
one man said he had been out of work for
15 months he was just going back to work
he said one of the most important things
for him was actually to connect with
other people
professional networks while he was out
of work to keep those relationships warm
because we all know that our
professional networks are often how we
get our next jobs yeah and if your gap
is tied to caring for a new baby for
example men and women now doing that as
well you know it says about one in five
us parents most are women are
stay-at-home parents so if you're
looking to re-enter the workplace after
that you can keep the networking bug
alive even if you have the baby strapped
to your chest and a little Bluetooth as
you know how to do that who's more
likely to have the gap in their in their
resume men or women well I mean this is
not a surprise not just because of
babies because of spouses because of
parents it's shifting but it's it's not
shifting as fast as I would like to see
it yet but you say you're saying cuz a
lot of people when they go back into the
workforce they're they're actually kind
of afraid no way they're gonna be seen
yeah and they should they shouldn't be
well it's not that they shouldn't be
it's
they should strategically get ahead of
it right you need to do the things that
are gonna best set you up for success
and you need to understand it's possible
and that alone is a change it wasn't
possible in the same way two decades ago
you just said something women taking
time off because of babies spouses what
do you mean spouses why are they taking
let's say you have an illness in your
family god forbid your spouse is
diagnosed with o take okay okay all
right that makes sense
confused words I can thank you Jesse
ample thank you very much